back in the day you kind of needed a
label to get
to your fans yeah because there's no
internet it's like yeah
it's like so technology was expensive
then
yeah now it's free labels they had the
money to do it
right now technology advanced to the
level where
you know it can't be controlled like
that and
and you know in one way so i think a lot
of artists today got an advantage
you know the advantage today is that you
can
use technology in a way that we couldn't
in the past
the other difference though is that
the the playing field you got so many
people
to be up against that also have the
internet for free
got you so it kind of balances itself
out when you have the og's like
oh y'all got it easier than us cause we
not really cause right right
the new cat's gotta go against a million
other people yeah
when you were probably the only person
rapping in your neighborhood right
because now everyone's rapping everyone
can get fruity loops everyone can go
buy a mic for a hundred dollars so so it
evens itself out
yeah it's like they got their little
perception the gift and the curses of
each era
even themselves out yeah for sure
because like now you got like you said
it's the
everything's so saturated it's like it's
like djing
you know back in the day you had to buy
records you had to learn how to actually
mix you know now you got a laptop you
download some songs
yeah you get a little controller and you
go do a gig
back in the day was not like that but
not you know you can literally play a
video
of a dj's old dj set
right here that's [ __ ] crazy well look
twisted thank you for coming through man
the legend twister
uh go get your new new project
appreciate you coming through
man let's get to it boom perfect much
love y'all